hey guys my name is DeSean oh and
welcome back to my C++ series today
we're going to talking about references
last week we talked about pointers so if
you didn't see that video you are 100%
going to have to because reference is a
really just an extension of pointers so
you need to be able to understand at
least at a basic level how pointers work
in order to actually get this video so
go ahead will be a link in the
description below if you haven't seen
the pointers video definitely watch that
okay so pointers and references are two
kind of key words that are tossed around
a lot in C++ and other languages they're
essentially the same thing though I just
want to start this video by saying that
pointers and references are pretty much
the same thing as far as what the
computer will actually do with them now
semantically so how we actually use them
and how we write them there are some
subtle differences but at the end of the
day references are just pointers usually
in disguise that's just all they are
it's just intact sugar on top of
pointers to make it a little bit easier
to read and a little bit easier to
follow a reference is essentially
exactly what it sounds like it's a way
for us to reference an existing variable
unlike a pointer where you could create
a new pointer variable and then set it
equal to a null pointer or something
like that that is equal to zero you
can't do that with references because
references has to reference an already
existing variable references themselves
are not new variable they don't really
occupy memory they don't really have
storage they're not like your typical
variables because what they are instead
is a reference to a variable I'm going
to be bringing up a few different
examples in this video however I'm going
to keep it brief
because the references aren't that
complicated and the best way really to
learn how to use them is actually to
start using them so adversaries goes on
we'll be using them all the time and
you'll see what kind of the best
practices or at least my opinion on what
the best practice is to do with
references however pohjanmaa doesn't
code let's say that I make a variable
I'll call it a and all political decide
is just going to be an integer if I want
to create a reference to that variable I
can do so by typing
type of the variable followed by an
ampersand note here that the ampersand
is actually part of the variable
declaration in the previous video about
pointers we learned that if we create a
pointer we can use the ampersand
operator here to actually take a memory
address of an existing variable it's
different here because the ampersand is
actually part of the type if not you can
see it's not actually next to an
existing variable it's part of the type
so just note that difference because
with a lot of people as soon as you see
an ampersand I think is the reference or
oh it's definitely an address off it's
kind of depending on context here so in
this case because it's next to the type
it's a reference so if we keep writing
this I'll call this wrap and I'll set
this equal to a and that's really all
you have to do there's no kind of weird
operator or something that we have to
use here we just set an equal to an
existing variable and so what we've done
now is we've essentially created
something called an alias because this
rest variable I say variables in quotes
here because it's not really a variable
it's just a reference like this rest
variable doesn't actually exist it just
exists in our source code if you compile
this code right now you're not going to
get two variables created a and rest
you're just going to have a what we can
do now is we can use wrap as if it was a
so if we set wrap now equal to two and
then print a we're on our program here
you're going to say that a is equal to
two now because we're printing a and
we've just changed crap to 2 because for
all intents and purposes rest is a we've
just created an alias for a and in this
case our reference isn't a pointer or
anything like that there's no need for
the compiler to actually create a new
variable if you compile this code it's
just going to after this we just set a
to 2 because that's really what we did
this is just something that we can write
in our source code to make our life
easier if we wish to alias a variable
now let's try something a little bit
more complicated suppose that we wanted
to write a function which was supposed
to increment an integer if we just write
the function
this and then do something like value
plus plus what will actually happen is
if I create my integer over here and
then I call increment with a parameter
what's going to happen here is since we
are just passing this by value you can
see that we're not passing this other
pointer or as a reference or anything
like that
it's actually going to copy this value
five each of this function just copy
it's going to create a brand new
variable called value with that so it's
almost as if we were to write something
like that that's exactly what will
happen so instead of that and I can
prove it of course if I just roll my
code here and we love this we're
actually going to still end up with five
printing to the cons well which can stay
over here what I need to do is I
actually need to pass this variable by
reference in order for it to increment
because what I really want to do is I
want to actually affect this variable
here so how can I achieve that how can I
actually modify this variable by passing
into a function now last time we talked
about pointers and remember pointed on
memory addresses so theoretically I hope
you're putting this together in your
mind because so exciting but
theoretically what we could do really
clever right is we could instead of
talking the actual value five into that
function which could pass the memory
address of this a variable because then
what we can do in that function is we
could look up that memory address see
that value five and then just modify
that that memory address we can write
through that memory address since we've
taught that memory resident function
look at that shot what although they'll
modify this to actually take in a
pointer and I'll just also call it value
and then what I'll do here in increment
is I'll pass the memory address of a
instead of just the value five it's now
passing the memory address of this
variable one more thing I'll have to do
is actually if you reference the value
so that we can actually write through
that memory instead of modifying the
pointer itself if I just do this without
the dereference it's going to just
increment that address right so points
are of course just memory address just
an integer if I do value for cloth
without the asterisk without the
dereference operator then it is just
going to increment my memory address not
the actual value there now because of
the order of operations it's actually
going to do the increment first
the reference so what I want to do
instead is the reference first and then
increment because I don't want to
increment the pointer and then be
reference that I want to dereference the
pointer first and then increment the
value at Point a so if I compile the
code on it you will see that I will get
do you think printing so awesome we've
successfully managed to pop and variable
by reference into a function however
there's many of our references so we can
do exactly what we just did here a lot
easier with less code and with less kind
of decorating our pin tax if we just use
a reference and that's what I would do
in this situation I would use a
reference so what we can do is rewrite
this to take in a reference instead of a
pointer and then what that means is that
I lose this whole need of dereferencing
I can change this back to exactly what
it was and then over here I don't need
to pass the memory address today I can
just pop in a and since it is being
passed by reference
we basically rewritten the code to do
exactly the same thing internally when
it gets compiled it will be exactly the
same as what we've written before
however this time it just looks nicer in
our source code again that's the only
difference so I run my program you can
see we get this so that is all the
references really are they are just
syntax childer references there is
nothing you can do with a reference that
you cannot do with a pointer pointers
are like references except they're even
more useful they're even more powerful
however if you can get away with using a
reference like what we just did here
absolutely use a reference because it's
going to be a lot cleaner and simpler to
read not the point is are really really
difficult to read but it will look a lot
cleaner in your source code one other
important thing that I want to mention
with references is that once you declare
a reference you cannot change what it
references what I mean by that is this
suppose that I had two integers i had a
and b and b were set to eight they were
set to five and then what i wanted to do
is declare a reference that was set to a
and then maybe later on in my code i
decided i actually you know what I want
to set my reference should be
referencing B can I do something like
that the answer is no you can't do that
what will happen in this case
is that it will effectively create a
reference to a and then when you decide
to set that
tickled to be it was just that a equal
to the value of being which is a so what
you will end up with here is a being
equal to a and B being equal to eight
that is that's it that's what you'll get
and of course because of that that also
means that when you declare a reference
you need to actually assign into
something you can't just do bit consider
to be compiler will not let you do that
it requires an initialize when you
declare a reference you have to
immediately assign it something because
it has to reference something because
remember it's not really a real variable
at the reference so in this example
specifically what would I do if I
actually wanted this kind of
functionality if I wanted to actually
change what rest or the reference of
well of course as I mentioned earlier
this isn't a real variable we would need
to create some kind of variable of sorts
that we could set up 2.28 first and then
later on we could switch it to point to
be and of course I keep saying the word
point in the hope you'll understand that
I'm talking about a point so instead of
this let's just make this a pointer we
can initially set it to the memory
address of a and then when I wanted to
switch to it being pointing to B I can
just switch it like this because
remember to actually start assessing the
value that this pointer is pointing to I
need to be reference the pointer first
and then state vehicle to something like
that so in this case I'm setting a equal
to two and in this case I'm setting B
equal to 1 and if I were to log both of
these they should be 2 and 1 and you can
see this AR all right that's pretty much
all I want to say really simple stuff
will be using reference there's a lot
more in the future again they're one of
those things that you just use all the
time like pointers so you'll see a lot
more examples down the road as this
variant progresses enjoy this video
please hit the like button you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram and
of course if you really enjoy this video
you can support me on patreon to make
sure that I can continue this if
applause series videos and make more
awesome videos in the future all right
next time
next time we're going to kick it up and
off I'll see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
[Music]